welcome to this video playing some tire
from Finland 96 checking let's play the
Moscow variation so quite a good
alternative to the to the open Sicilian
so should I go yeah maybe let's go for
the maracas see bind yeah okay let's do
this first this is um yeah sort of a
peroxy Hedgehog Hedgehog but do it
LightSquared bishops off this is in fact
an interesting point about the the
hedgehogs quite often the exchange of
the light squared Bishop is good for
black especially if Y display g3 here I
like it with the bishops off mmm how to
play maybe i can i can even play with f4
f4 queen nia 351 something like that i
have fianchetto would so
the only thing I'm asking what service
may be a bit too too early yeah I want I
want the King out of this and now yeah
queen of 31 if I always have night f5 so
if I've isn't isn't the problem he might
play with g 6 p.m. ok route belongs on
do you want I guess
so how to continue now it's probably
going to play g6 and Bishop g7 the
question is what about f five is a five
good move yeah I guess so I need to do
that to have some by TM f five and if
you place 95 I'm going to play Queen h3
attacking e6 this is the idea anyway get
the Queen to h3 and pressurize the e6
bond so take first on Queen a three
yeah I do this first
yeah how is he going to going to protect
is six is yeah normal 95 of course this
leads to interesting complication so I
didn't this I didn't expect at all messy
going to really as he going to play with
with g5 maybe maybe so this is so this
is surprising I thought that this would
simply give me too much attack
okay this is I need to do anyway and
there are various ideas now look F 695
these kind of ideas at the moment he has
got quindi aid of course
hmm should I blame night I could also
play Knight f3 knight f32 gt5 which is
quite quite dangerous night e to F 45 is
also a point interesting okay let's
speed up a bit
yeah it feels it feels really dangerous
for black button so Knight to g5 or is
there some some better idea now g5 via
night maybe Ned h5 is a good reply
I take you five de five this doesn't
really help
okay let's and let's do this now at age
five I've got night GE for and then
night d5 isn't isn't bad
it's also Disick thing
yeah this is in fact very good for white
how does he even protect you six plus
the s95 this is not exactly a bad as
well 95 yeah maybe hey maybe can play
rock the aid 9526 I don't see an
immediate win after that it looks nice
but is it winning
and don't really want to exchange Queens
also considering the time situation
you
neither form so another idea my deaf
form
yeah you can he can just take it
amazingly enough the other one to four
maybe
very hard to believe I must have missed
something very nice along the way this
wreck of a position yeah yeah I probably
missed something
time warning they can take with the
Queen what's a sick joke maybe you will
find it no taking what the Queen was
much stronger check
check check black for fits on time yeah
you got a good very slow at some point
yeah but I'm really curious where there
was the win yeah this position is
completely on the ropes like so let's
let's let's check a bit and now Bishop
f5 and g four winds okay yeah yeah it's
always yeah it's it's not so difficult I
could have seen that cannot move 9006
now and if he takes us just this one
setting up a big Fork yeah you don't
want to somehow give up your Bishop and
what I did term it probably kept some
some advantage but around here black yes
sir like Assam has improved considerably
alright thanks for watching